hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is the Samsung Galaxy camera so the
easiest way to describe this product is
to take a samsung galaxy s3 phone take
out the ability to make phone calls
which basically gives you a mini tablet
then slap on a 16 megapixel camera and
lens and a flash and that's how Samsung
Galaxy cameras are made now but
seriously this guy has gotten quite a
bit of attention during the holiday
season and I did do an initial hands-on
with this guy a few weeks ago but my
overall thoughts are still very mixed
and here's why first off with the pros
it's a pretty decent build quality no
doubt about that it feels durable no
creaking or anything like that it's also
relatively small I'm not going to say
it's the smallest digital camera out
there but it definitely counts as a
portable camera I suppose you could
install Skype on it and if you really
wanted to you can make calls on it but I
don't think most people are going to
want to hold this thing up to their ear
it's a bit chunky not exactly small
enough to be pocketable anyway so this
begins to separate itself from other
digital cameras thanks to its
connectivity this is probably the most
connected camera out there right now
it's essentially a mini tablet on the
back so you can open up the bottom and
throw in a SIM card and connect to Wi-Fi
and 4G if you want so you can install
any app from the Google Play Store this
is a really well connected camera it's
running Android 4.1 jelly bean so
project butter is there and it's just as
responsive and fast as you'd expect it
to be just like a galaxy s3 the user
interface is also the next place it
differentiates itself it takes advantage
of that four point eight inch Super
AMOLED touchscreen on the back very
different from most other cameras and
that provides a lot of room for control
so it gives you just about the same
level of control as a regular digital
camera so it can take you know full
automatic or you can use one of the many
smart modes which acts like a preset
setting for certain shooting scenarios
and most of them work pretty well if you
pick correctly and if you're really
feeling daring this camera has some full
manual modes as well it has an aperture
priority mode brightness changing mode a
full manual or shutter priority and
whichever setting you're in you can use
the sliders to basically adjust the
camera setting and you can view the
preview behind all those sliders in real
time so in full manual you can move all
these sliders and when you feel like you
have that shot dialed in
you can just tap out and take your
picture as a side note the only issue I
had with the speed of the camera was
moving from a photo-taking mode to a
photo viewing mode sometimes it seemed
like it took an extra second to actually
do what you asked it to do once you push
the button on the screen obviously
things can't be instantaneous but that's
just something I noticed while I started
using it I'm sure this can be fixed also
with a software update from Samsung
but the biggest drawback of this camera
is while the camera itself I gave it to
my not so tech-savvy sister to take
pictures during the recent holiday so of
course it was in full auto indoors and a
lot of the shots taken turned out pretty
well but the ISO is really only
acceptable up to about 1600 from the
sensor that you can go up to 6400 if
you're ok with the visible noise in the
image even though on auto there is no
flash you can hit the manual flash
pop-up button but beginners won't know
this so the shutter speed went all the
way down to 1/8 and 1/4 of a second so
motional motion blur ends up being a
problem with some photos indoors the
video quality was also hit or miss it
really depends on the light available
just like a smartphone there can be a
few pros though autofocus was pretty
quick during video and for photos as
well so the shots were able to be taken
pretty quickly and the 21 X optical zoom
is nice that can be tremendously useful
especially outdoors what's awkward
though as a camera is that it takes some
microSD cards instead of regular SD
cards like a phone so but then again it
does have 8 gigabytes of internal
storage so it's whatever you want you
might not need any cards at all thing is
this is supposed to be a camera first
but ironically that's where most of its
shortcomings are in fact the Galaxy Note
2 went shot for shot for shot for shot
with this camera until we broke out that
21 X optical zoom while our phones have
to rely on digital zoom but I mean let's
face it no other compact camera has a
1.4 gigahertz quad-core processor no
other camera has this huge 4.8 inch HD
LED touchscreen display on the back no
other camera runs Android 4.1 jelly bean
and has full access to the Play Store
with Instagram and all of its apps and
games hardly any other cameras out there
are even Wi-Fi capable they're barely
Wi-Fi capable and this one is 4G capable
and can share photos literally as they
are taken to services like Instagram and
Dropbox in Gmail and Google Plus that's
what makes this a
different product but for the price this
F two point eight to five point nine
lens and a slightly small 16 megapixel
sensor and the image and video quality
basically that this produces doesn't
really match up and I think that's where
Samsung kind of swung and missed with
this product that being said I have
faith in Samsung to get it right on the
next release and I am absolutely looking
forward to the Samsung Galaxy camera 2
and that's the one I would recommend
waiting for
[Music]